shrine now 25 years 2050 Arabs
enshrinement
yeah well it it's such an honor and it's
gone by so fast but Class of 93 is
pretty good one
Larry little Bill Walsh Chuck Noland
Walter Payton and myself and you know
unfortunately it's just Larry and myself
are left and we missed so Bill and Chuck
and Walter but just coming out of that
room is an amazing experience with all
the Hall of Famers in a huge group of
Hall of Famers this year yeah yeah no we
have about six minutes to chat right now
so I want to get right in can you what
is it like in that room for us for us
mere mortals trying to figure out what's
going on well there's a lot of emotion
number one a lot of guys expressing
their gratitude talking to the new class
telling them what to expect also you
know tell them to keep their speeches
shorter because there's so many so many
guys but how does that get communicated
to them very sternly but it's it's also
ignored but the thing about the room is
is the greatest players of all time are
in there I mean to sit there and see
Paul Hornung to see Jerry Kramer finally
make all of him Joe Namath is over there
Dick Butkus is over here Willie Lanier
it is just mind-blowing at times that's
right
Paul Hornung he's been enshrined for 32
years along with Ken Houston they went
in together you know in 1986 and so just
what is it like for you I guess to look
around and see all those folks who are
also called Hall of Famers I mean what
is that what is that like well we've we
all considered a fraternity a team a
family and so so many of us come back
every year and so we get caught up on
our families we get caught up on you
know what are you doing now how can we
help you hear what's going on so you
look forward to seeing the guys every
year you look forward to complaining
about how the game is played now and
things like that but you know I grew up
a tremendous football fan and my father
was the voice of the 49ers for 20 odd
years I was a ball boy for you know John
Brody on the sidelines so I got to see
Dick Butkus and Gale Sayers up
and to see Johnny you and to see Bart
Starr and and all those great Packer
team so this is really just a
continuation of a dream Dan Fouts here
on the Rich Eisen show in the couple
minutes I have with you what did you
think of the helmet rules first step as
we saw last night the Hall of Fame Game
yeah I think when you see it out in the
open it's an obvious call the thing
that's concerning to a lot of guys is in
the trenches how's it going to be called
on third and goal I mean there's a you
got to lead with your helmet at times it
running back is trying to get into the
end zone so it'll be interesting to
follow no question and having you know
the job as an analyst it can be very
frustrating at times because the rules
are now so subjective now don't you
think they nailed the catch rule though
down pat don't you think do you think
you're gonna be up there in the booth on
CBS saying what's the catch not a catch
this year I hope so I think that's the
goal is that it becomes more clear to us
and obviously to the fans and to the
players themselves but you know that's
what happened when you bring in an
instant replay now you become it's more
subjective and now you've become talking
about lawyers and putting rules in in
the rulebook in language that is not
football language what do you think I
thought I give you the floor on him
getting a great great selection there I
mean what he has done in his career
building franchises he was the first NFL
contact I had when I was at the
University of Oregon I was a junior and
he was there looking at Bobby Moore aka
Ahmad Rashad and I happen to have a good
game that day and so he sat down with me
and asked me a few questions and he was
in his Hawaiian shirt he's with the
dolphins at the time I think even had
flip-flops on and it was raining in
Eugene so I go way back with Bobby
better and I'm so proud that he's in the
hole and now Don Coryell has got to be
next right well he has to be next I mean
nobody changed the game more than Don
Coryell both sides of the ball
the way the games played today the
proliferation of the passing game and
also defense is having to adjust with
nickel defensive backs and dime backs
now so Coryell definitely deserves an
shortly before you sat down Charlie
joiner knocked on the window I said well
he wanted me to make sure I mentioned
him mr. joiner
he's my senior so I have to show him the
property yes your senior I'm seeing that
22 years in the Hall of Fame for him 18
years he played 239 games nobody had
played more as a wide receiver nobody
had caught more passes for more yardage
than Charlie Joyner when he retired he
definitely is a Hall of family well you
are too sir I appreciate you stopping in
here and you know taking some time
coming out of the other Nitschke
luncheon there it's always a pleasure to
be with the greats it used to be yet
same to you Dan Fouts here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience